how to avoid writing proposals so I made
a video not too long ago called what did
I call it why I don't write proposals
and in that video I talked about how I
hate writing proposals I hate writing
proposals and instead rather work with
clients who understand what I do and I
could spend my time working on servicing
them and building great things instead
of bogged down admin work and and making
proposals so I got a message from one of
my youtube viewers love you guys Vicky
who wrote in to ask I wish I saw this
video earlier this week a potential
client found me and reached out we
chatted and then she asked me for a
proposal although I don't mind I was a
bit surprised she asked since she was
reaching out to me what should I have
done differently thank you so much for
the amazing value you always bring so
Vicky this is a really important
question now we'll get into the nuts and
bolts and the hands on them actually how
to do it first of all understand that
it's natural for clients or prospects to
want a proposal because it's risky and
scary for them right they're thinking
about this huge project they don't know
you from anybody else they want some
comfort and security that by looking at
this proposal that you put together it
makes them feel safer it makes them feel
like you can deliver on this thing how I
like to do it and this is the best
approach I found is you take this big
scary project and you break it down and
find the most painful individual spot
that you can help out with so I don't
know what you do you didn't say in your
comment but let's say let's say your
graphic designer
okay you're a graphic designer a new
client comes to you and says I need a
logo a website I need an email template
I need business cards and I need Flyers
this is huge project right I don't know
what you would pour let's say it's
$50,000 okay so you have this $50,000
potential project with the client that's
a big number for client to say we're
gonna work with you it's usually not
gonna happen just over a phone call
right that's a scary number so they're
gonna say well put together proposal and
we'll
while we're viewing and then you can
compare you against everybody else and
all the other proposals what I would do
is through the conversation identify
with them what the single most important
most painful part is what sparked this
whole project if you think about a big
project is usually one thing that
started it and then it became this
bigger project and they had to go out
and get budget for it so for example for
that maybe it's the logo okay let's use
that as an example the logo is the most
painful part they looked at the logo in
like this does not represent us anymore
so we need a new logo and so because we
need a new logo then we need a new
website we're gonna need a new flyer we
need new business cards we need new
newsletter templates all that stuff so
became this big project what I would do
is work with them just on the logo so
say you charge a thousand bucks to do a
local let's just throw that number out
there work with them on just the logo
because that's the most painful part for
them and it's so much easier for them to
say yes to a thousand dollar project and
not need a huge proposal than a fifty
thousand dollar project right and if you
blow them away
you give them a great logo you provide
great service you're the best supplier
they've ever had and across any of their
business the rest of that deal and more
is just going to come to you without
having the proposal at all right you do
a great job in the logo they love it
everybody Saint Vicki is the best person
ever now you have to deliver on that
which I hope you will they're just gonna
give you the business card and give you
the website and give you the newsletter
template because they love you and they
love everything you're doing they know
that you're gonna deliver the biggest
point of a proposal is to reduce the
risk right help me make an educated
decision and reduce the risk that I'm
going to screw up but by working with
you on a simple project that means a lot
to them where you're over delivering
like crazy you've reduced that you've
eliminated all the risk because they
love working with you they know you can
deliver and so that you're just gonna be
their person ongoing from now on for all
of their projects that $50,000 project
and beyond
and you never had their own proposal
that's how you do it it works I promise
you believe for those you're watching
like the video give it a thumbs up below
leave a comment ask a question I'll make
a video response and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much and I'll see you soon